Coping files in Gradle is simple.
We start by simply declaring a new task,
and
specifying the type of the task as Copy.
Of course this task won't
actually do anything,
because we haven't told it what file
we'd like copied, and to where.
Simplest example is to copy
the contents of one folder to another.
We use the copy tasks from
method to add sources, and
the into method to
specify the destination.
This copy task will copy
the contents of the images directory
into the build directory.
We can specify files to include or
exclude, our filters can use wild cards,
allowing us to do things like, include
all files that match a certain pattern,
or have a particular file extension.
This combination of source,
destination, inclusions and
exclusions is called a copy spec.
Let's configure our task to
only include jpeg images,
by calling the include method,
and passing a file pattern.
We can also configure a single copy
task to copy from multiple sources.
Copy specs can be hierarchical, which
is particularly useful when you want to
exclude certain files from
a particular sub-folder, or
a specific Include them in another.
Let's configure a copy task which
copies all JPEGs into one folder, and
all GIFs into another.
We define two child copy specs.
One to include only JPEG files, and
the other to include only GIFs.
We also specify the folder we
want to copy these files into.
These folders will be created as
subfolders, under the root copy
destination, the result being that
JPEGs will be copied to build/jpeg, and
all GIFT files will be
copied to build/gif.
Gradle provides task types for
creating archives like ZIP or TAR files.
Archive tasks are nearly identical to
copy tasks, except instead of specifying
a destination directory,
we specify an archive name.
Let's zip up all files
in out images directory.
We use the Zip task base name,
and destinationDir properties
to tell Gradle what to name the archive,
and where to create it.
Note the the destinationDir
property takes a Java file object.
Luckily, the Gradle project interface
provides a convenience method for
creating files.
We can do similar things with
archive tasks and trial copy specs.
We can create an archive
which puts JPEGs and
GIFs into their own
directories inside the archive.
The only difference from
our copy task example,
is that we specify the archive name and
the destination.
Sometimes we want to delete
files during our builds,
usually to clean up
previous build outputs.
We can use the delete task to delete
files or folders in our project.
Here we have a task that
deletes the build folder.